b
all right for people joining this live
stream we are continuing
our review of spatial statistics
functionality
which is intended for the upcoming
version of language
um and somebody who should be on mute
isn't on mute
um
okay let's see where we'll be at last
time
we had started going through this first
section
and we you just looked in on one of
those homogeneity measures
we looked at intensity all right so
first of all we need this spatial point
data
which is you know usually when we have a
function whose name ends in data
it returns data it doesn't
represent oh oh
um well temporal data you know
represents data okay that's one example
i know of
so that's not that's that's an example
but um
we have another one in travel directions
data
okay optimal flow data
but that's sort of sort of a return
um
so which which one i mean so
all right
let's understand
is there a future spatial region data
yeah so that need need to be there's a
different
container for continuous data
well but i'm asking a different question
i'm asking let's say that the spatial
data consists of
the counties of blah blah ah there is
potentially
so this is part of a bigger area called
stochastic geometry
in which case you have random lines
random planes
um you know other elements basically
right
and and in principle you have um
uh regions collections of regions
like leaves for instance covering the
ground
or the underlying case paper is built
out of
lines fibers yes
okay but so what we're thinking about
here what what this
container represents
is something that has been spatialized
just like a time series
is you know contextualized in time this
is contextualized in space
yeah right and in principle
the set of things here so right now here
the set of things
which can be in any number of dimensions
what is the analog of geographics for
this
i think if you just want the raw i mean
i don't think that geographics has this
notion of annotations
um but if you just want a bunch of
points
then geoposition is a multi-container as
well
no no i understand that i understand
that i'm asking the question if i if i
want
to get from special point data i just
want to make
a well so spatial point data is
attach spatial coordinates
to a piece of data right it is the
analog of event series
for sort of the other i mean
you can very well have spatial point
data without any annotations
any other data then so you can have an
event series without
what do you do with an event series
where you just want to manipulate it
using date histogram and so on
yeah we we didn't build it that way
because really event series was supposed
to be discrete time
time series which is not the same as a
as a
as a as a truly event-oriented data
um that we named it as but so it's a
little bit misnamed i think that that's
what we should redesign it for
because that's what it became through
the design process
which to be like this in the sense that
it just maintains
events with additional annotations
basically
and there's no way that you combine them
in any particular way
but you can do you can do temporal
statistics
on it and so on you can have intel
so for instance if you think of
earthquakes if you think events in time
you can very well talk about intensity
functions over time
it's also the case that in the case of
events over time
like the humanly collected data is often
aggregated so for instance when you get
traffic data you often get traffic
counts per 15 minute hour and so on or
people entering a store you get sort of
aggregated combination space and time
potentially potentially that that can
also happen potentially
um but but but in the car counting data
and stuff that's just
this is sort of things in time okay but
the main point was
server data okay so hold on hold on hold
on so what we've got here
is we've got primitives that represent
um you know primitives that represent
where
and we've got potentially
values that represent what
yeah and i think this should be an
association by you know i think it
should be documented as an association
here
but it's in which way do you mean this
thing here should be documented as an
association
the payload for the point should be oh i
see which association
yeah i think you're right i think it
should be okay should i just change it
or
is somebody else who else is on the
school go shows here she'll she's
she's the one that's been i'm taking
notes okay
um okay so so it's
where and what so in the case of
it took us a long time to get to this
that did its annotations
and hence associations by the way
stephen so it's we went the long way
around
just through the history okay fine fine
okay
so
i i'm just to comment on this okay
you know to me it seems like the
left-hand side
it's very much like a time series or an
event series
and i can imagine that that left hand
side could in principle have primitives
in it
that aren't you know it can default when
you just give a list of values
that represents a point but if you you
might give an
actual line as that left-hand side
that is a symbolic representation of a
line as the left-hand left-hand side
and say on that line this is the payload
so to speak
i i don't think that we can guarantee
anything sort of in the evolution of
that object
what do you mean i think the best we
could do is sort of you know be a
container that you can
query things out so so let's just
understand if we
your geo-region value plot okay
geo-region value plot has what is its
form
what is its representation of um
i think it's just region and those can
be entities
no i know i know i know geo region oh
god this
crazy thing with the streaming
whatever by the way um who's
taking notes here
is that gosher is it avery who's taking
or andrea
taking general notes here could you
please comment that
that when i type this in this is the
12-2 prototype
okay first of all i i really don't think
this is working right
this this way that this did you see what
i'm seeing here
yes yes so you should comment on that
the second thing is
once i have it i can't click it
in other words i there's something wrong
with the way selection works when i'm
at this point okay i'm going to report
it to the documentation scene
okay all right so here we've got a
pattern region arrow value
right yeah okay
so but but so
but then um the
there need to be multi-valued by the way
by the way by the way by the way
does it support this geo-region value
plot now support region which is now
geoisable
i don't know okay jose cause the updates
the updates that are coming have to do
with
you know being able to i forget why we
do
no i know why we're doing it it was um
okay so look the region you know
clearly okay and also
obviously geo region value plot should
somehow be able to eat
spatial point data of some kind
we have just we have discussed that for
geographics geographics will be able to
take
special data and get the spatial
information good
and show there good but so jose you want
you aren't saying anything when we're
talking about whether
geo region value plot supports region on
the left hand side here
uh i don't know for sure that would be a
question for brett but i don't think it
does
okay so that's a bug so let's get it
fixed yep
right okay so
um okay but but notice all right so
what i'm what i keep on pointing out
here is i don't think the word point is
right here
um i mean if
the problem is when we make them very
general we can't really guarantee
anything
um they become yeah but that's the way
it works i mean
the look the fact is this
should become a container for
arbitrary spatially tagged data
and by the way
wait a minute what is this so this is a
transpose of the way that this works
here right
we need keys doesn't there's no keys
there
there's only a single value to begin
with right no in this case there is but
i mean we we should obviously extend
your origin value plot
to be consistent with this but going to
value plot
we have a new function called point
value plot that does that
does what that allows for
any number of of uh values
where is it it's we looked at it in the
visualization
uh review meeting
so in principle we could consider having
a function called region value plot
which isn't a geo region value plot
right so point value plot does point
value plot
it works for geo data right yes
both both geo and non-geo right so
so why don't we have a region value plot
yeah we could we could probably
okay add that let's plan on that
need some yeah i know i need some
thought but but
um okay so then
i'm coming back to
i mean in that sort of family
i am do understand spatial point data
does make some sense to
distinguish from general spatial data
yeah um
all right for this version okay can we
tag it as experimental for this version
because i think we're going to want
spatial data
as a general thing going forward yeah
i just want to make sure that you
understand one um
and i'm fine with it being experimental
i don't care particularly
so but there's one thing that i just
want to make sure you understand
this is discrete data
that there is no interpolation between
the trees you know
okay yeah good
right there is another object that the
people want which is something that's
interpolated between them i understand
which has some kind of density
spatial density data yeah actually when
you derive the density you get a field
so that's one of those continuous things
i see so it's spatial field data
effectively
yes
are we going to call it that i don't
know
that was a it was an interesting name i
think it's not a bad name
i mean in that way
what is the general category of thing
points lines regions
that is you know what you have is where
it is type thing
as opposed to the field
well in visualization we call them
glyphs
um yeah no i know hello a tree is a
glyph
yeah no no of course not um
the thing is that you know for for
the stochastic geometry side i think
that sort of the applications fall off
pretty quickly
from points because points itself is
pretty hard and everything else is not
easier
um yeah okay anyway let's look at let's
look at this function some more okay
so i'm getting sold on it being called
spatial point data and so then
then point value plot
as well as list plot right works
directly on this right
yes but which one are you really
promoting are you really point promoting
no point value plot came in late but
that's what we're going to be promoting
because point value plot is sort of the
universal
kind of tool that works for me right the
point value plot then annotates
the values with something right yes
i think you should promote both of them
and and and i think we are i mean
this plot is just like just use the the
original
points yeah and list point plot 3d for
3d data
okay this is useful i hope it refers to
um yeah don't forget to make this refer
to georgian value plot
and vice versa of course
so this will be get a there's as many
rev
this this is going to be kind of rich
because often when you have
it's not hard to imagine particularly
with the
um entities that we have let's say a
city
is a point but there's an awful lot of
potential
attributes sure or properties for a city
that you might
and how might those how will those be
converted from
data to visualization so that's that's
part of
what what that is is modular
right by the way this dimensions i hope
it recorded layers for the point how are
you playing
it returns wait a minute wait wait wait
wait i hope it
roger can you hear me yes i hope
dimensions returns the actual dimensions
as i would think it is not two or three
or something
what do you mean by that what's nothing
what dimensions the function dimensions
returns
what does it what does dimensions mean
here
yeah that's a good question i mean it
says dimensionality of point coordinates
i know basically the length of those
well is it
gosha can you say please
so yeah so what you want you want to
have the the real world
dimensions so if your points are in you
know one d or two
okay so it's the wrong name for that
it's the wrong name
right it's obviously the wrong name so
that's should we dimension i think
that's what we put in the ally that form
why doesn't this work can you remove the
s please
yes so that's my bed of not updating the
documentation
okay that's fine
point coordinates of the first
configuration what does that mean
that means that configuration is
basically like a set
so you can have multiple sets for the
points i don't see that in this
documentation
it is the last input where it's actually
with annotations
so this is how you input multiple point
configurations
this isn't right this isn't right this
isn't how you're doing this
right isn't it the case that it's point
arrow value point arrow value point
no no they all have keys
so yeah so you have a whole list of
valves for each key
corresponding to the list of points so
that's the transpose of geo region value
plot
because it doesn't it's not really
comparable the points here are usually
huge think of all the trees
okay you're going to have annotations
wait wait
wait wait wait wait you have a transpose
of what we should be doing
here we got to support both forms
every machine learning function supports
both forms that's what we need to do
here
and that's what we can do okay what do
you mean by both forms
okay so here's what i mean you've got
something which says
you know you've got a list of points pt
one pt
two et cetera those two uh
essentially val one val two right
no they have a keys they have to have
keys
why why do they have to have i mean they
don't have to have keys the key will be
generated automatically if you do not
specify
what the heck are you going to figure
out what that key is then you have to go
look it up then right
right it's going to be enumerated
i don't understand i don't understand
why do you need keys
do you know what's how else do you know
how to access to do to
know how to access your annotations to
know which but
most of your [ __ ] your functions are
saying mean intensity
well yeah these are our descriptives our
descriptive statistics doesn't look at
the values
okay okay this is in preparation
hold on hold on hold on hold on but
there is an extension to all this
descriptive statistics that does work
on the value domains too okay
fine so what i'm saying is i'm saying
that
what we've done in other functions is
you can either have
you know a list of points goes to a list
of values
or you need the keys too so i don't know
what you mean by transfer
i understand so we do this right
that's what we do in every other
function
right so every individual point can be
handled separately like this
sure that can be done i mean it's very
inefficient but there can be i don't
care
i don't care i know you don't think
we've got 20 points efficiency
no no no we i don't care because you're
wrong
it's yes it's inefficient when you have
10 000 points
but the issue is can somebody understand
what to do in an example where there are
10 points
sure we can do okay okay it's the same
as what we've done with with all the
other functions so then
i i don't know what we do in the case
where
okay so this is i mean look at how it
works for something like classify
right classify has all these different
cases
right example goes to class
and then list of examples goes to list
of classes
see what i'm saying that's that's the
kind of thing we need to do here
yeah except we have three things instead
of two things
because
well you've also got just the list of
points without their keys
without any values so now the question
that i'm asking is
i'm sure it's the case that there will
be data sets
where every point just has a particular
value
you know the height of the tree you
don't care about 17
keys for you know height and this and
that and the other you've just got data
where there's one value for every point
right and so that's why i'm suggesting
this form
be supported for that where you don't
have to give a key but since
i don't understand how you're doing the
extraction yet
right but gosh you understand what i'm
saying
yes
i do it's just that uh exactly that
that's
you know this way of inputting the the
the
annotations it just seems very
cumbersome if you have many points
of course it is and most of our well
that just most of our
data that we found in the world you know
it's correct
okay so i'm gonna give you points okay
why don't we list
our company offices around the world
okay
how many of them are there not very many
we can just list them like this
great thanks okay
the
so that wasn't the point i was
addressing the point i was addressing
was this form here
right where you are merely given a
single value for every point where you
don't have an association
of with keys and values for every point
do you see what i'm saying
well that's that's the input that it's
understood no no no no no no i'm
you're right now you are insisting on
having a key for every value
i'm saying you shouldn't do that i'm
asking you is there a problem with that
there is no problem with that um i
explained it before that if you don't
provide the keys the keys will be
generated automatically
but i'm not sure i'm not sure that makes
sense and we need to look through
where you're using that fact because i
don't think that's going to work well
you need to enumerate the
the you know the the the values the
annotations in some way because if you
give multiple
no no no multiple information for each
point
no no no no no you're not understanding
my point this
this about points this this form
is just listing a single value for every
point
we're right to list multiple values yes
i will have keys and you'll know the
names yes
of each of those sub values what i'm
saying is this is a case where there's
just
one value for each point there's no
automatically generated key
there's just one value well there is a
key why
why not because we don't need it
but we have to refer to that
we'll have to look we'll have to what if
you want to add some more you know
then you know annotations then then what
then you're out of luck then this form
isn't going to work for you you're going
to have to redo it
right in other words if you if you're
going to take this data if the data that
you thought you had isn't the data you
actually want to have
then absolutely you're going to have to
go through but
generating an automatically generated
key is completely crazy
right in this case what we've got we've
already had this example
for machine learning for lots of other
things where you can either have a value
or you can have an association of keys
and values
right so let's look through where you're
using the values to understand how you
extract the values
in these two cases make sense
sure it's not as crazy as
i'm not being as crazy as you're making
it sound i'm being
um there are some examples of that
if you want to look at the examples then
there's there's an
annotation section okay so hold on hold
on first thing we want to look at here
you've also got this thing i mean okay
it is a disease with you guys
that you do the very complicated case
you don't do the simple case so
i'm dealing with the other end right i'm
dealing with a stupid simple case and i
want to make sure it works properly
and then we interpolate to get to the
you know the fancy complicated case
all right this business about
configurations
i don't okay
what is a configuration it's a point
pattern so it's a collection of points
we don't call them point patterns but
that's what they're usually called in
the literature
that's the object you don't study
individual point you study point
patterns
i understand you need several of them uh
if you're gonna
derive statistics you have a model that
generates those you need to deal with
the collection of
possible stakeholders temporal data
versus time series
yeah this is this is the temporal data
version that's the thing that's needed
for
the models and the data to go together
no
no it's not what's needed there's plenty
to be done by just having
the map of one forest having a map of
multiple forests
is a different more complicated case
this is this case here right
yes yes okay so let's let's make sure we
don't confuse everybody
when did i start editing this okay but
look
i think this should say
represents a collection
of spatial points
um with positions
i i would personally do it you know
since that is a list
we're going to use in the rest of the
literature here we use configuration
though
as a as a concept oh yeah i i don't
think it's a great concept i think we
should i think we've got to start simple
and we've got to talk about a collection
of spatial points that's what
the everyday person knows sure yes the
six experts in this
call them configurations but they call
them patterns
okay then let's them let's call them
let's
have that mapping okay i don't think
configuration is a good name i mean i
think it
it's a it's not a name i mean i don't
see what's wrong with just a collection
of spatial points
now now in this case is there a reason
why you don't say pt1 pt2 etc
here yes because also a geo position
because they can yeah exactly they can
be geopositioned they can drop sections
that's okay but i mean just pt1 with
positions
of spatial points with positions the
positions are described below
i don't we took all that out to not get
an unreasonable
box up there no no but i understand that
you don't have to describe it
specified by pt1
you know pt2 dot dot dot
because that way you're saying to people
what the form of this thing is here
no but you point your position have them
inside of itself
it doesn't have 0.1.2 we have a little
table
in the notes that explains the form okay
fair point
fair point that's okay
okay
okay look represents a collection of
spatial points
um and is it constrained to be
what is the observation region what do
you mean observation region
within this region we found all the
points of this type
all the birds nests all the insects
all the trees whatever it is that you
study all the earthquakes
meaning that if there is no point in
this part of the region it really was
not
the region is also to tell you that for
example some part of
of the region of interest might be
devoided of points
yes and also the issue is that here if
you give
you know points in the region the points
which are outside of the region will be
discarded in the
creation of why don't we say with
bounding region
reg no no please don't do that
because because it's always called
observation religion i think
in literature look it's okay look
there is a literature there is a
specialized field that calls these
things point patterns
right there's a specialized field that
has a bunch of names i'm trying to get
it so that
we're not talking about observations has
a very specific meaning for us we have
geo balance we have all kinds of
bounding
is this not a bounding region in that
sense no
okay i mean it is it's
there is much smaller bounding regions
you know and if you say bounding region
we think that it's one of those smaller
ones
what do you mean by smaller
if you're okay
when you say bounding region normally
it's like a plot range there can be
points outside of the plot range but we
are only considering the ones inside the
plot range
yeah i mean as i say it's significant
that there are empty parts in there okay
but the bounding region can usually be
much smaller
and if you write bounding region that we
use for so many other things what do you
mean by smaller i don't understand what
you're meaning by the word smaller
you mean smaller in physical size or
smaller concept
smaller in physical size okay but so
what are we going to say because in
which case you get
the notion of observations is is that is
that is assuming a use case for these
points that we do not need to assume
you see what i'm saying it does so let's
not assume that let's just
um
um
okay so how do we how do we characterize
this region without saying observation
um assumed to be within the region reg
or something
or just within the region rag
no there's a whole there's a whole
reference entry for observation region
observation region queue
okay what what do you mean what what i
don't understand
um maybe it's not listed it's on the
guide pages it's listed
it's the the observation region satisfy
conditions okay like what what isn't
found
so it's not there well that's a really
weird thing to have
it's spatial observation region
hue okay if you scroll down a bit on the
spatial point data
you cannot click on that because it's
listed there
oh god
yeah they're often called windows
but windows then appear in a filtering
you know domain in in in language so
none of these none of these look come on
guys
come on come on the okay
look let's not make the mistake yes
there is an existing
field that uses this stuff by experts
with expert terminology
the goal is to have this so it's
actually usable by people who don't know
all that expert terminology so i don't
think this is going to cut it
right i don't understand can be an
observation
spatial statistics what the heck
you mean observation region or something
yes
but but this isn't you see there's no
statistics needed here we've got lots of
things here
that are barely what anybody would call
statistics making a histogram
a point intensity histogram is hardly
you know yes
of course it is statistics in some sense
but um um okay what are we going to call
this
because this is what what you're saying
is this is the region
i i personally think this this at this
level
the documentation should just say within
the region reg
because i think that's what you see what
i'm saying because i think that's enough
to say here
you can explain how that region is being
used later
because that that lets people understand
roughly what's going on
i mean observation region is just like
nobody's going to understand that
except the sex experts
but let's let's keep going here so so
the next thing we have is
the use case of um
so now you've got something which says
points oops
points arrow vowels
dot dot dot right that's the case where
um you know associates
the values vowels
with the positions
points is that right
yes okay so then the next case we have
here
is
this case here
right the next case we have
and then
um
this one here should be say something
like
okay so how do we disambiguate that from
the case where we have an individual
i see i see so this is
the next case here is pt1
arrow data
1 right pt2 arrow data 2
etc right
is that right
that's the transpose case right
what's data well either value
or an association
okay and then the final case shouldn't
you write that out a little bit more
detail so you can see that then
well i will say it here i mean the
um but the final case here is multiple
collections
represents
now if you have multiple collections of
points
how do you deal with that is it spatial
data points one
points two etc
did you understand what i'm saying do
you mean access it or
no no no no no no specify it right
do you understand what i'm saying there
are multiple collections of points there
are two
types of trees right and you have their
positions
not everybody is no it's not an
annotation you just told me
that you've got this notion of
collections right or what you're calling
right so you put the list points one
comma
you didn't document that because we
document it with annotations so if you
remove that from the picture you get
exactly the the but you don't do it with
annotations because you didn't have it
with annotations right
the annotations are something different
right this is what you're saying
okay so this represents
multiple collections of spatial points
right and then you have this case
where you've got
multiple collections of spatial points
with annotations
i think okay let's let's keep going and
understand how this works
now
um
okay so now here
so i don't see any problem with calling
this
if you insist on calling it observation
region i still think it's weird but it's
okay
i mean i think you could just call it
region here
and this is this does not make sense
i don't know what we call it this
because we haven't really had that
in the case of list plot for example
what do we call those
multiple when list plot has multiple
data sets
we call them data sets usually in our
informal documentation at least
yeah right although that now has a
technical meaning for us
i think we just removed the name data
sets and called them data one data too
so no no i understand that but in this
accessor this is crazy i'm sorry this is
no no absolutely not i mean
what okay look what you're trying to do
is you're trying to hack the fact that
the design
allows you to both have the thing not on
a list and the thing in a list uh
and multiple things in a list right
that's why you've got these two
different things here
right well yes because you want you know
if you have just one
observation set you want to have easy
accessories that make sense
i know in the sense like we have with
temporal data that we have path
you know and all values and then we have
values list
if you want we have multiple parts i
know let's not use temporal data as an
example of
design prowess because temporal data you
know made the same mistake that you guys
are about to make here which is it's a
very complicated thing
that is a relevance to experts but the
actual use case that people want is a
single path
time series 98 of the time
and that wasn't made easy to do and
involved all this weird stuff with paths
and so on
and let's not make that mistake again
know the the generic case has to work
with um uh
um you know so i understand you've got
this issue here
of right how to distinguish yeah okay
we can deal with that let's let's let
but let's understand what we're trying
to do first
okay so so
all right so let's see so we've got
now um
uh you know people on live stream are
wonderfully confused about some of these
things
like speculating that configuration is a
schema no it's not
that's what's confusing it's just a
collection of points it's not the schema
for a configuration you might reasonably
think would be something like
the the collection of keys and so on but
it isn't
um there's a complaint from somebody
about time series
we're working on it i hope
um
uh let's just look at a few of these
live streams
uh steve is suggesting that um
uh we reward regular attendees who made
great suggestions here
in some way and yes that's a very fine
idea and i i think we've had some
some um the right way to do that is
conferences
and things like this that's that's i
think the right um
uh and and uh the beta test program and
so on
and that's a good suggestion and
somebody should look into that
um the uh okay
which graphs can take special point data
and display it along with the annotation
so i guess
what um brian is asking there is which
things like list plot
can you feed this thing too what's the
answer to that
so we've made a an initial list and
we've made it work in a lot of them
okay like bubble charts list plot list
point plot 3d
uh of existing which other existing ones
goshaw
i mean the the the least plot in lisp 3d
but you know in this way you only you
know see points
and value plot is the one when you
really want to see the attributes right
so the point value plot is really the
the thing that takes
you know yeah understandable can i can i
just can i just clarify
for you guys again right that you are
thinking of the very complicated case
where people have a hundred thousand
data points
seven different you know whatever's in
seven different collections
with 18 attributes each right but there
is also a case
where they just have the map of a
hundred
trees and they just have their positions
and we want that to work nicely right
without
people having to so so yes so we want
this to be supported
into the the list uh plot and then at
least point plot 3d
and that just only takes the the
locations and it will just print you at
points
uh presented but what about list plot 3d
for example because it connects no it's
a surface
i understand but but but in the case no
no but but look in this case where we
have points and values
we can perfectly well show those values
as heights in list plot 3d
just like for example a surveyor went
out and got
elevation data and fed them into spatial
point data
right did you know that these are real
we haven't really built a type system
for the values right but um you know so
so for instance let's say that the value
there is
birch and pine fine then then it's a
different issue
right but in the case where if you if
you feed that in
to you know list plot 3d it's not going
to work
and um but i think we should make it so
that
in the case where you know just as
let's plot 3d takes point arrow value
i think takes point error value
input so this can so you should be able
to feed from here to this point point
let's plot 3d
yeah okay so i think we can
i mean after this release we can make
that work fine and we can
okay so so let's go back down here um
this is this is going to take a while
longer this let me just look at the
counter here
oh my gosh we're supposed to do
geography and dates
live stream in a moment why don't we ask
the um
uh soon why don't we ask the people who
were in that
to um to join this meeting it's an
overlapping group
and and also don't think it'd be bad to
have brett
and um
and um these other guys here so if we
can just ask them
can we do that please yes thank you
um okay luis is commenting spatial
statistics functionality will be useful
to help devise policy measures
concerning mobility in smart cities
yes uh okay sandra is asking can we get
local density somehow
and fluid dynamics one generally finds
local density by being the inverse of
the area
of the associated voronois cell
point intensity yes that's the density
yes there's an implementation that uses
that as well
the method yes so so if i
if i were to take
okay so let's say i say
are we bothering to give the region i
see you're giving that region there
right so let's let's pick because it
creates different
region if you don't provide the region
so you get a different special point
data
you know i get it for the same set of
points
okay so that isn't right that should
have just been the summary blob right
is that prototype
yes
gosh who are you going to say well i
will not say that probably what you have
is the outdated documentation
and therefore your prototype build might
be ahead of it
right so i would suggest to recreate the
special
for some reason though this wasn't fixed
andrea can you please
please ask to make sure somebody figures
out the bug
that is causing messages to be put in a
separate window on my machine
i thought i had asked for that really to
get fixed
okay i'm going to tell that to roger and
the people okay
it'll be for the fifth time roughly
so tell them to put it in the meeting
that i have this afternoon to fix some
other things that have been trailing
that one needs to be there too okay
so spatial point data point thread so
this is just a bug here
this is not working right
it's just an internal bug right yes
scotia
i think so because that worked for me
earlier
so okay no problem all right
i just want to get some example here so
that i can play with things okay
look like the region didn't work there
okay
okay so now what is this okay so that's
the lanai
if you would like voronoi then you need
to put point intensity your data comma
string voronoi okay so you don't need a
linear interpolation
that was very that was that was a much
easier answer i think than sander was
expecting
but okay so now what do i do with this
point intensity function how do i plot
it
so uh it is a it is based on the
locations
so now you are in 2d so you can you can
use
plotting that would plot this as a
function of of two
arguments
uh i'm guessing it's going to take a
list of a list of yes
points it's a location so it's a vector
x y
in the argument
okay what's the range of values i think
i said
so x is we are in a disk of zero one
and it's centered at zero one sorry
i work too much in the unit discs yes
okay not bad
nice actually very nice so if i was
the intensity would be pretty constant
because you use
random points oh absolutely yeah
why is that beeping why is it beeping
plot 3d probably oh yeah yeah
slimy
okay fine all right so now why isn't
this
those are voronoi's that isn't smoothed
in anyway
no so those are the raw
so if i were if i were to take fewer
points here
um
because it's based on the point
locations
okay what's that picture there
that's the illustration for the
intensity no no i understand
why is it in a square box like that
okay so this is now so i don't really
understand what happened here
so i would have expected this to have
voronoi regions
that show the intensity i'm now confused
how this is working
did you understand my question did you
want to use
that don't foreign isn't it the same
type of thing that i should get here i
can use voronoi just for the sake of
using voronoi but
i don't understand why it isn't why it
doesn't have discrete
is that what i'm supposed to do
yeah okay well that's not working okay
but
in any case i don't understand this i
don't understand that box
and then i don't understand why this is
not
showing in the dilemma triangulation why
is it showing these smooth pieces or
or am i wrong that it's smooth pieces
are they really peaceful no that piece
was linear
okay that's why if you wanted it
constant that's why you needed to
specify go right
oh okay but if i do this for example i
should see these things
have flat
is that right is that what you expect
yeah
okay you space linear why
why is the cookie cutter so so jagged
here
given that there are very few points
do you understand my question is that
just a question of the adaptive plotting
in plot3d
i think that's the best
but so your function there
is oh yeah beautiful
magnificent great that's exactly what i
expected
i mean give or take might even be a
useful example
maybe you already have one like this do
you have an example like this
do you have an example like this i don't
think we do know
okay so there you have it
okay um
um could whoever's making that clicking
noise please put themselves
um okay
complaint about discrete and continuous
distinction the data
i don't understand that one um
okay ethan is saying he wishes that
spatial point data of points comma
values worked i think that's and i i
think
the correct ask there is points arrow
values which will work
sander is asking the same question i was
asking why call these things
configurations
yeah um configuration was an alternative
name to pattern
right i think collection is a fine name
that's
i mean okay ethan is commenting it's
having to use
thread so can i comment on the
collection versus configuration yes
because collection for me means that you
just have
um you know points in a unorganized
manner and configuration actually means
that you
pay attention to where the points are
located
you know collection you can just put
things into a bag and you don't care how
they
no but that's what we're saying exactly
we're saying
collection of spatial points that's what
we're saying collection of spatial
points
it's not a the fact that it's a
configuration it's a collection of
points
and points by their nature have
coordinates
okay i think it's going to work kosher
i know i mean i i mean there was a
reason i know we considered collection
yeah but and i can't remember exactly
why we rejected it but there was many
iterations there
okay all right okay so let's go back
down to this
um uh oh this question this comment of
ethan's about
about threading here let's take a look
at this this is probably a different
all right so let's take a look here
we've got
that's covered by the overhaul of the
region value plot and 12.2
so this is fixed is what will be once
the branch merges
okay so the samples are our heights will
work there's no need for a thread
correct great okay that was a good
answer
um
okay um
okay
ethan is commenting on please make the
automatic plot points option
in plot smarter that is a good
suggestion after all these years
may be worth looking at brett i don't
think we've looked at that in years
do we have a definition on smarter
[Laughter]
well no but that's a valid point i mean
i think that we can
actually yeah i mean every few every few
versions we up these plot point values
because computers have gotten faster and
things like this
we haven't really upped them very much
you know so i think that we can use more
resources
if moore's law is true we should be able
to use more resources yeah but most law
died 10 years
ago no intel
still believes it's true so we believe
it's yeah
all right okay well if they're engineers
i was gonna say i think i saw a headline
a couple of weeks ago about
moore's law being replaced by something
i don't remember what the something was
oh don't tell me it'll be it'll it's oh
it wasn't quite
it's nvidia law you know it's it's fine
do that for gpus that's funny
um okay
all right let's take a look here so what
you're now saying is so we've got these
geo
uh right
great okay geo regions all right fine so
so for example if i were to say here
just to understand how this works
if i were to say um
let's say state capitals
in the us okay and now i just
say see i'm i'm being
spatial
the way to build but it's supported
sorry you you're saying this will work
yes
okay and right now if i say geo position
of this
it would be yeah if it's a list of geo
positions yes
okay so now i take that object and i say
geographics of this
is that correct
um no because you didn't specify the
graphic primitive so and also for for
the for the build we don't have
multiple problems here they're multiple
terms why is this a syntax error
that's a question for brett
um it is not a special error it's an
unknown
primitive and that's how the front why
isn't it pinking
uh it probably is but it's a pink is not
comfortable
yeah it's hidden in some way and i
thought we were updating the design of
these
yellow uh boxes we went through that
like a year ago
did that not happen completely wrong
group of people i'm guessing
but but that would be your team wouldn't
it but maybe not
okay so andrea that's something for you
please to chase down
talk to path about it okay
okay you understood what i was talking
about there yes
yes and i also can go are you sure are
you sure are you sure are you sure
well okay you can you can quote from the
live stream recording
yes
[Music]
so this will be supported but it's not
supported yet so these will produce
a map of the area given by the points
and the region okay with the points
indicated by whatever the default
point indication is from a geo and
geographics right
so our idea was to follow what we do in
other cases which is you would have to
say point
i mean especially so if you do
geographics of that geo position
you would behave the same
i unders so you're saying okay so if i
have
geographics of that geo position it
won't actually have points right
yeah i get what you're saying yeah
geographics a point
of that geoposition will have points
right great okay
and if you don't have the point then you
get the same region of the earth shown
just no points i get it it's correct
okay so average number of points per
area is the next thing so what we're
saying here
so the name is mean point intensity i
should have changed this
the the review notebook okay so so the
it's mean point intensity now this word
intensity
why is it intensity not density
we introduced it in all of our
statistics functions
like histogram and smooth histogram and
all of those guys
um and as opposed to the densities that
we also have there
and the intensities have the unit of
of events per
language their accounts not probably
that accounts per area
kills per length counts per area
accounts per volume this is not a pdf
it's a count
it's not a normalized pdf exactly
so so in that context it's no longer a
density per se
because in there in that world densities
are normalized i know that they're not
in all other words but worlds but
i think it's too weird here
why because i don't think i mean this is
a density it's the density of cities per
square mile
it's not the intensity of cities i mean
it's like like uh
you know there's an intense invasion of
alien spacecraft or something and they
are
you know in this amount per square mile
might be intensity but i don't think
otherwise this is a density isn't it
i mean i i don't see why this fails to
be a density
well not in a mathematical sense i think
that's where the argument goes and so
when we when we think when we think in
terms of
you know normal english usage humans you
think density because it's dense
populated
density and so
hence we have intensity so we are not
introducing some
you know having do not have the clash of
concepts
okay but i don't think intensity is the
right name i don't know whether density
is the right name but i don't think
intensity is the right name
um what is it
i mean what really is this what
mathematically is it
it's an intensity no i've never heard of
an intensity well
in functional analysis is there a
concept of intensity i've never heard of
it
so if you if and in a density you
integrate over the region
and i'm well aware you got one i know
this one you get
okay i want to know i want to know
when people use the word intensity other
than an
optics which is something completely
different for this concept
of the not normalized to one thing is
that
is that a known terminology or is that
something we're inventing
no it's it's in in this in the spatial
literature no no no not spatial
statistics literature
i'm talking about elsewhere okay in the
case of a histogram for example
the counts per you know when you're
talking about
absolute counts per unit length
basically
per unit you know value of the whatever
you call it what do you call it what do
you call the thing at the values in the
in the x-axis on a histogram
length okay all right so then
but that corresponds to the intensity
setting in the histogram
i know i know i'm asking you what is the
mathematical name
for counts per unit length in a
histogram
because i've never heard the term
intensity
i mean maybe you have because
we added it to histogram in like version
eight
well okay i i'd forgotten it already
yes that's not what histogram just has
the notion of counts
right no no i mean histogram has like a
half dozen
i know it does i know i know it does
right and one of them is intensity
i bet i've never understood that i mean
i use histogram all the time
but you've never used the intensity
setting crazy thing
do you see these crazy waves that it's
just
it's like it's like it's like a
jellyfish with it you know doing it
swimming or something
except jellyfish are like slow and
graceful about it whereas
okay um
okay so at the bottom of the thing there
all right i admit i barely noticed this
let's see so uh someone is commenting
here
frequency is that what it is it's not
frequency it's the it's um
sander is pointing us to the wikipedia
article on number density
yeah well that's what this is it's the
number density
i've never heard that well it's a common
term in physics
usually denoted lowercase n or sometimes
lowercase
f and statistical mechanics
well okay so let's let's go back to what
we're what we're doing here okay so
we've got
we've got um
i have to say oh gosh
okay let's argue against
point actually point density
okay mean point density is a number
yes point density
is a function but why is it called point
density function
because it is a function it's not
the otherwise i would expect it to be
the point density which is more like the
mean point density
yeah i don't know can we get them
evaluated at a point two and then when
you skip that argument it gives a
function
return i think so i don't see why we
shouldn't be able to do that
so then it's then it follows that what
we've done with many other things when
we
carry it when we make it shorter it has
to return a whole function instead
i think that's right i mean i think
that's like what we do for nearest for
example
gosh did you do you get that i mean so
so then the idea would be okay so we've
got mean
point i i strongly think it should be
called mean point density
but that let's we'll argue about that in
a second
um
yeah i mean i think it's i think it's
the right term but okay so then
then we would say um point density
function and it would take data
i mean right now that's the return value
so what i was saying is
point density data comma number gives a
number
that's fine yeah exactly
and then point density data without the
without that second thing
just like nearest returns function right
but now the only thing that's a little
confusing here
is with nearest for example what we get
is a nearest function
yeah so here you would get the point
density function but then you're putting
in a point density function you're
getting now but that's what i say you
shouldn't do
well that's why we have the just point
intensity and histogram pointing
because they all in the return point all
of these estimators return point
intensity function
yes whatever the estimation method no
this intensity name is just wrong
i don't know what the density is right
but intensity is wrong
um
yeah but that's the idea that three of
them compute and they return the point
intensity function
which you can then operate and you know
plot and such what's our analogy for
that
so point density so nearest i see so
that's one of the analogies is the data
distribution for example which is
returned from different distributions
and like
smooth kernel distribution gives you the
data distribution of the given type
and we have empirical distribution
histogram and and so on
yes
i really like density and i really don't
like intensity just
argue again for me why is density wrong
because it doesn't integrate to one so
by definition this is not density that
that's the that's the main argument
and all the uh
uses intensity for that matter
so you you are you know you the the
pushing the game you saw the expert
all the all the experts kind of area in
a way that they just use intensity not
to be confused
with the density do they have an
intensity do they have a notion
yes if you if you if you if you can
um uh normalize that you know that then
it you know
can you normalize it doesn't make sense
for these purposes okay so then it
doesn't make sense so then why are they
not calling it
i mean okay you know if you can
okay the reason it doesn't make sense is
because you would otherwise
the
what is this this is no
no it's the wrong way around look a pdf
okay the expected the mean in a pdf
right is the integral of p of x
times x dx right normalized by p of x
right but what you've got here when you
say mean point intensity
that's a different thing that's asking
it's the number of points per unit area
okay i'm going to
ask for support from from like
uh you know when you integrate so when
you integrate this over the region then
you get the number
total number of points that that's what
we care about
i think that so this this this this is
going in in the sense of the number
okay i understand so your point is the
mean point
blank when integrated over the volume
you're saying gives you the number of
points yes
so a mean oh i'm very confused
hey jose do you understand can you give
me a physics analogy to this
as a physicist myself i am with you that
this is more density than intensity
because
to us intensity immediately reflects
luminous intensity
density with respect to angles not not
with respect to
volume i think luminous intensity is
probably from the same origin
because you have the number of photons
per
per area
yes it is and that's what they're trying
to riff on
in calling this intensity i think
but but but explain to me the thing i'm
very confused by is this mean
is i mean is this number
equal to the number of points divided by
the area
mean point intensity is number of points
divided by area is that correct
yeah okay
god i hate this name intensity it's just
okay what other
words can we think of here
um
okay so the issue is point density you
claim when we multiply by the area
instead of getting one which is what you
think we should get for density
we get the number of points
so you know this reminds me of kind of
the latent heat
versus or the the heat capacity versus
the specific heat
and i suspect that there's an analogy
you know density of a material
is not hell again you know it's mass per
unit volume
and you see that's a great example of a
density
where you know it's mass per unit volume
right so you multiply it by the volume
you don't get one you get the mass
sure which is the direct analog of this
situation
where you multiply up by the area and
you get
um the uh uh
you know the number of cities or
whatever not one
um
yeah actually push acts is pointing out
on our live stream this thing is
actually equal to
the mean point volume or mean point area
right is is the
this is the no it isn't no it isn't
because it's got wrong units never mind
forget that sorry
personally i support mean point density
and i'd like to understand
again the analogy that i would give is
density of a material
which does not normalize to one that's
correct
right but um i
how to put it you see material it's a
continuous
it's a continuous object what we're
talking here are events so if you said
for example
lightning you have to say intense
lightning because you have lots of
lightning per unit
area so your your intensity is high
no you it's a good try
that's a good try actually
you're just trying to use something
which has is intense
because because you know in the in the
language we use
interchangeably sometimes you know when
you're going through this
intensity and density are used
interchangeably yeah be honest
that's that's what i've seen and so
mathematically you want to distinguish
you know what you expect when you
integrate
and therefore we don't call it density
because we do not get one
so we call it intensity because we get
something different
but intensity says the wrong thing i
mean that's the
that's the problem it's i mean no that
doesn't i mean one can go with density
too
maybe i don't know exactly what the
consequences are for the rest of them
i would like to try it let's let's work
through what the consequences are
okay let's look at these other things
here so this would be point density
which i understand
very well that makes a lot of sense to
me point intensity is like
each point when when i see point
intensity i'm thinking these are glowing
points
of various kinds of intensities
point density tells me something about
you know it's points per unit
whatever so okay so the other things we
have what is histogram
point density so all of these are
so histogram is when you use
a bin to create smoothing
it's it's it's aggregation you know what
a histogram is
spatial ones and then smooth it's
uh is a non-parametric kernel density
estimators of the
yeah right so every city has a gaussian
around it
it's the it's the okay fine sorry what
was the the histogram one is what again
for the cities what do you put on this
is using bins
it's using bins well you can you can
specify them there's like a whole
language to specify the bins so you
start with the bins
and they and then you collect points to
the beans in the point intensity you
start with the points and you create the
bins based on the points
locations and here you say i want to be
in my region in that way
use this so there's a bin spec there yes
yes
and so really that just changes the area
computation
or is there something beyond that
no it changes the this moving so exactly
because otherwise
yeah right so the bigger if you
okay the extreme cases you only have one
bin
right you know then you only have one
value so this is analogous to
geohistogram what is that
explain to me how this fits in with
geohistogram it fits
perfectly well with your histogram
except it gives a function out
that you can evaluate and it trims
and it also works in 3d and so okay so
i've got a question so what is the
analog
for a histogram of how do
what function do i get out it's one of
the empirical distribution functions
right
empirical distribution is basically the
the
the thing that is the histogram function
no histogram distribution is
i see empirical makes you know it's an
extreme
and varying bin sized thing it's where
every point
is sort of it's its own delimiter
it's about as finely resolved as you can
get okay but so the analog here
is this is histogram distribution
yes
and let me understand something else the
the various distributions that we have
the multivariate distributions and so on
how do they relate to spatial point data
okay interesting in various ways so
when when um
if you're okay so you can always
generate
a you can have what's called
inhomogeneous poisson point process
and they can take a distribution and so
you can use a distribution
to now generate spatial point data
following that distribution
and it works for uh
point intensity right the way
one thing with those uh point
collections have
is that they're basically the points are
viewed as independent of each other they
they don't talk to each other
okay no i guess other other models of
data where points sort of talk to each
other they they don't want to get too
close so one naive thing that i might
want
is something where i have a distribution
where i give you
a you know a random distribution you
know i don't know a weibull distribution
or something and i say
make me throw down points
so that their uh point density
function will be that distribution is
that right
sort of i mean so we have various ways
in which you can use distributions in
generating point
uh but the thing i just said i don't
think it's completely stupid because i
mean that's basically i mean so you what
you can what you can do with that for
example is to create clusters that would
have viable radial distribution
so the distance from the cloud for the
cluster center will be viable
but the point is that viable
so i'm fine with that but i'm i'm saying
let's say my trees
let's say i have trees and i want you
know the
the um you know the the seedlings grow
in such a way that there's a certain
distribution of
of there's a certain distribution of
dens of local densities of trees
so we have a constructor for just that
okay then homogeneous poisson point
process
no in this case what you would want from
that description would be
um cluster point processes go down
further oh yeah
well yeah i mean in general that's
homogeneous but if you know that
your seedlings come from from a center
that's going to be the
cluster processes yes exactly so that
would be name and scott
what you can do
okay so this is then so what i would do
i would would feed into this neyman
scott thing
my uh my sort of seedling
survival distribution thingy or whatever
it is
um so this is the general case but wait
a minute why is this mu and lambda here
mu is the the the intensity per se of
the centers for the clusters and lambda
is the average number of points in the
cluster
this is this is this the kind of the the
how are we what about the thing i'm
asking let's say
giant trees you know some kind of uh
geo-engineering project
i'm planting giant trees across the u.s
and um uh i want them with a certain you
know
average density how would i get that
then you use the inhomogeneous poisson
point process
because that gives you the that you know
then you can put the distribution like
the intensity
all over your region where you want to
put your trees what the cluster is doing
it's really creating
the next generation from the you know
the clusters like the centers of the
from the parent let's say process so
this is this is that you have the parent
which is distributed
as a as a poisson point process and then
you create the offsprings of this parent
around which are the clusters that's how
that's the control do you have here
and the way that to put the parents or
your original trees into the region then
if you know this is uniform you use
poisson point process if you know that
it's
not uniform and you you want to specify
your intensity functions and you use the
inhomogeneous poisson point process
okay okay so let's say we replace the
word intensity here with density
does this make a nonsense of this
i don't think it does
well the point is that mu here stands
for the for the
for the for the mean number of of you
know like the
the mean point intensity right
if it's a number that's going to be
known as mean point density
right where density is in temperature
right uh
i mean i am i am struggling with the
fact that the things has to
you know integrate to one and then like
everything will have to be rescaled so
like i'm trying to
kind of compensate for that to you know
in this
vision just the world of densities so
right i mean brian on our livestream is
saying it boils down to who will use
this most statisticians are
non-statisticians
no right that's the i mean
um i mean this is the challenge you know
a lot of terminology and statistics
is sufficiently unfriendly to the
outside world so to speak
that it either doesn't get used or it
gets used only as an incantation
by people who don't understand what it
means um
i mean so so you have to keep in mind
first that there's massive
simplification that we have affected for
this
first of all good i'm glad to hear it
this is a 2000 function package
yes i i get it yeah right
i'm not surprised well done i mean i'm
not even i'm not even going to ask what
the
what all the the crazy stuff that um all
right so
okay so then
okay let's look at this random point
configuration
so random point
is something that selects a single
random point in a region right
what this is doing now no the random
point
can can can generate single point but
you can give to random point you can
give a number of points you want in the
region and it simulates the points which
are uniformly
and independently from each other
exactly right right right
so here what we would what it differs
here it's that you can give a process
the point process so
specified as in in a different way and
hence the configuration because you
place the points
according to certain scheme which is the
intensity function
in this case i don't have an objection
to the word configuration
i don't think i don't know what else we
call it
because we don't we don't we can't call
it pattern right
so this is called random point patterns
in the literature
and since pattern was taken
i think this is an okay name for this
um let me understand what the arguments
actually are
so the first thing is a point process
you're saying
so default values wait a minute where
are where are some net where are some
names for processors
that i can use here go down to the
examples
there's like a whole guide page of them
but we can look at some of the examples
it was on point process is the
the most common this is where you got
the uniform distribution it's the least
interesting in a way
[Laughter]
that looks at the world you know like
the whole big
problem to resolve is whether we're
uniform they distribute
yes yeah galaxies no i know i know i
used to know people who did that for a
living
including some of the ones who
originated the whole modern star
counts right so i want to say that if
you now
generate the configuration for the
personal point process
you get the number of points
automatically because that follows
poison distribution
so here the difference is that she do
not give specific number of points
because this is random
what are those parameters this is the
the mean
the mu is the mean point intensity in
the poisson point process and two it's
the dimension in which we are working
because you need to specify that's what
so let me let me just try to understand
so
so the 10 in this case would be
basically
what the heck is that spatial point
sorry that's that's that's a prototype
that's
that's a prototype that's no problem
yeah okay so that's not needed anymore
no i need to go and update the the you
know the documentation
so probably yeah okay all right okay so
here
um that number 10
if i were to explain that that is the
density of points
in the region that doesn't sound wrong
to me
that's the number of points per unit
area right yes
that's that's a freaking density i'm
sorry
um okay
okay but so it's and if the two was a
three that would be the number of points
per unit volume per unit volume right
um and so just to understand this case
right so just to to do this case here
and now i'm going to say what can i say
just say list plot of this
right sure um
that's not gonna work in in the
prototype build yet so what you can do
is to use the points
accessory for that sorry we had to the
we had a collision with the branches so
to have them
built running properly you know the
support has been this you know
you know that's the problem is that you
have trees you had a collision with the
branches because
because radial distribution function
okay um so
okay hold on i just want to understand
something here because i'm a little bit
confused by
one thing here
okay so why am i not getting per unit
area here let's forget this disc let me
use a rectangle here
okay why am i not getting on the order
of 10 points there why am i getting a
lot more than 10
you got 11 points that's what they like
that form tells you number of points 11
oh i see
okay so i'm just bad at estimating these
things fine
this is not the exact number that you're
gonna get it's the the expected number
i see it's a random variable that yeah
fine okay that's fine all right um
okay cool so then then if i want
again to me as a naive user of this the
most common thing i'd want
is the radial distribution function to
have some form
and you say i get that using this
inhomogeneous press on point process
that sounds extremely obscure no no no
no
um go back to the processes if you want
to
okay i mean by the way if you want to
understand what the radial distribution
function that's that's the part of
descriptive statistics you didn't look
at yet
yeah this is the pair correlation
function for example
well i would say ripley k
for god's sake we can't call it if
that's the radial distribution function
it should not be called ripley k
the radial distribution function is a
well-known concept in many fields
right but this is what it what it's
called in the
in the spatial that's weird
okay but in every other field it's
called the radial distribution function
uh but it's not the function if you get
the number well actually maybe if it's
function of the radius that's what
you're saying
in that way what i'm saying is
but again you're not gonna you're not
getting a density here just want to
point out it's the expected number so
you're gonna get again the
the the you know something okay fine no
the distribution
the radial distribution function should
be
the probability to get you know what is
the radial distribution well that's per
if you talk about probability the pair
correlation is the probability
density of finding two points within
distance r apart
maybe that's what you're looking for and
also the nearest neighbor g and empty
space f
ares probabilities for different events
so they they are actually okay so if i
say nearest neighbor g
i i'm looking for the function which
tells me
as a function of of um oh great
just make sure that nearest neighbor
graph comes before nearest neighbor g
in this auto completer can andrea that's
something for you please you repeat the
gun please
i'm sorry
i was gonna say at that particular state
yeah go ahead you know it's running into
the auto completer
putting exact matches at the top
so the question is what's the completion
when you don't have the g there
correct nice
i think you should point out this the
suffix i mean this is a
rare case of a weird suffix
in autocompletion do you see oh i run
into this all the time
trying to type normal distribution
actually i've never noticed this case i
i i can see that when the probability
is sufficiently weighted towards the non
i don't think this is correct
what it's doing here i don't think it
should do this i think that the
probability
that you're trying to type this is this
a prefix
of of um you know of nearest neighbor
graph is so much higher than this is
intended to be nearest neighbor g
i don't think i've noticed this case
before this is something that we should
feed to the user assistance folk can we
do that do i need to do that
i can send that one to them
okay you should try typing normal
distribution it's lots of fun
okay well i think i have noticed that
but i didn't internalize what was going
on
okay normal d is okay it's right but
like in the process of getting there
it's like
norms and there's just a different one
always at the top because
it keeps exactly so listen listen i want
to make the radial distribution function
which is i want to plot given that i'm
at a particular point here
what is the density of points going out
from that point
how do i get that function
oh that we don't have for a particular
point in space
we showed these ladies these have
statistical meaning
here so they are they're two concepts
going around here one is
from what's called a typical point which
means from any
of the point in the point collections
you know regardless of which one you
pick that's the distribution you're
going to see
whatever one of those functions the
other one is from a generic
what do we call that location for
location which means any point in the
region that you gave
but not you know which which may not
which with probability one is not going
to be one of the existing points
and that could you can imagine this when
talking about tornadoes
you're not talking about the distance
between tornadoes you are interested how
many tornadoes from my location
you know within some radius yeah or from
any location is what this
right these things give you okay all
right but i i believe unless i'm
completely confused
that in statistical mechanics and in
endless studies of
you know stars et cetera et cetera et
cetera that the radial distribution
function is a thing
of of of of significance that is
starting from a point what's the
probability to find another point so so
but you you
give the point from which you start no
you don't give it
you're simply asking averaged over all
points oh yeah but that's what we just
that
is what we did then i misunderstood what
you said nearest neighbor g gives you
that this is the probability of finding
a point within a distance
r from any point in your data okay so if
i say this so that's the newest neighbor
yeah nearest neighbor g don't look it up
that doesn't look because that will
be a very inefficient way of doing right
so can you close the
the the square bracket after the first
argument and then apply to r
what's a bit there's something weird
there's something what's what's 30 oh
because 60
36 oh it's graphics graphics okay so i
wanted
to okay
what the heck oh and maybe i just talked
maybe the distance is okay
yes so you want to go smaller oh very
nice
okay so this is the probability to find
a point within that shell yes and you
see that it's cumulative
this is the cumulative distribution
function because of course when you
increase r you have a larger probability
this
includes everything right okay i think
the radial distribution function is not
cumulative that is it's the it is the
derivative of this but it makes
well if you differentiate that
you you get some pdf but this is i mean
the idea is that when you radially look
around
if you increase your radius it includes
all the points
that were already there so this concept
it has to be cumulative
okay so sander is common in fluid
dynamics it's frequently called
rdf the radial distribution function so
there is a concept of what we're talking
about here so let's just figure out what
it is
and it's a concept people need
okay um
let's look at the wikipedia page radio
there it is beautiful radial
distribution function from anna jones
model
per correlation function well we have it
it's called pair correlation g
yeah that's the derivative that's a
shell yeah yeah exactly
yeah we have that illustration exactly
okay so good
so then then there would be good to have
one of those um
also known as statements right yes
i'm making notes
okay why is this taking forever
i think it's because it's optimized too
thank you if you evaluate that
uh input argument before the plot has
this
if that's going to evaluate every time
you get a new r yeah it's a
heavy evaluation
load it has to be outside the
r
doesn't have to i mean otherwise
evaluate doesn't do anything
yeah okay you're all right that was the
issue
now why does this ploop out after point
four
probably don't have any
i mean what's pair correlation g percent
35 of
0.5 or 0.6 or something
yeah it's probably like a missing or
none or something or
not indeterminate
is that the right thing okay pair
correlation that's saying
that's saying above that distance
what does that mean and why does this
thing
give up there as well no it's just
constant one it doesn't give up so
logically if you if you you know if you
if you
count all the points then probability of
of you know if you
if you are within a certain radius and
all the points of your data set are
within this radius then probability of
finding a point is one
and hence you can you know can say that
it's flat it flattens out
finding a point at a greater distance
it's just zero isn't it
why isn't the power correlation zero no
because one is cumulative and one is not
so
the point is if you go if you nearest
neighbor g if you go
you know in a larger radius you
encapsulate all the points so you have
for sure you're going to find the
neighbor and the correlation it's not a
cumulative object
i understand but but why is that saying
indeterminate why isn't that saying one
when it's outside the region because
you've found every point
i think there is no data no if it's
actually accumulating the
pair correlations or something then the
indeterminates could be corrupted
and so that goes to something which we
call which which we call max radius the
property
and
i don't know that makes sense what makes
sense hold on hold on
gosh what are you saying makes sense
that doesn't make sense
are you defending the fact that it
should be indeterminate in which case i
need to understand why right well
what i'm trying to yeah just thinking
because that
whether it is reasonable to look
you know for the points um at that
distance
um i don't think one could say zero
because we don't know anything outside
of the region
that i should just say yeah you're
saying okay so let me let me
characterize what you're saying so
you're saying given an observation
region
as you're calling it if you ask for a
nearest neighbor function that goes
outside the region it's like we just
don't know
so indeterminate is correct but
okay right but that's something you
don't have
in in a data distribution
do you have do you have something in
like an empirical distribution which
gives you the range of
of do you have an analog of observation
region for empirical distribution
domain
which by the way will be a much better
name than observation region
oh if you had adam here you would have a
big argument
yeah um
sander is saying that he thinks it
should go to zero this pair correlation
function but i think the argument for
if you just don't know it you just don't
know it it's not unreasonable
um yeah i mean don't we have some
missing
should it be into i mean or should it be
say missing
maybe it'd be better to say missing
i don't i think we're better in handling
indeterminates than missing in the
system
i think missing is we have
missing stuff we're missing well but the
the missing kind of indicates that you
know how to maybe compute but you don't
and indeterminate maybe indicates in the
the way that
you cannot compute so
like i mean somehow for me the missing
means that you know that it's
not available now but it might be
somewhere
an indeterminate means that how no
matter how hard you try or not compute
that and hence determine it
so somehow for me that's logic
in favor of indeterminate sorry i was
just sending
christopher note commenting that confirm
i don't think triggers on indeterminate
and it probably should
right does it let's see no it doesn't
on the other hand if i say
right um
okay it's a failure and dollar failed
and whatever
much stronger statement than
indeterminate oh absolutely it's a
question of what the default
i mean you can always give a uh with
confirm match you can always give an
explicit list of things to trigger on
it's a question what the default
behavior for confirmed would be
because confirm does trigger or missing
right so i think it should trigger an
indeterminate i don't see an argument
before it shouldn't
um
okay we are really messing around
messing about timing here and i know
that we have a
we're definitely not finished with this
process now i
expected us to have at least now i'm
kind of thinking two more
but i i think we might be able to nail
it in one more but i think
um this is very nice functionality very
nice very interesting functionality i
i actually had no idea this was such a
rich area
oh yeah
right but i think it's a rabbit hole too
important
to be left to the spatial statistics
aficionados
should be left to the statistical
mechanics aficionados
well right that's a different it's a
different collection
um
collection or configuration right
thank you thank you
you know there are there are some
angular measures which i invented at one
point in the
longest and past that called fox wolfram
variables that are used to characterize
that basically things to do with
spherical harmonics that characterize uh
you can think about them this way at
least
characterize the um uh
angular distributions of configurations
of things
i hadn't thought about those in a long
time
anyway um the uh
um
um okay
uh it's probably
so it's what that what those are for is
characterizing if you have one of these
things and it's in the shape
of a you know is it ellipsoidal is it
circular
is it whatever you understand what i'm
saying
so it's a way of characterizing in a
independent obviously you're talking
about those angular measures
yes so i i guess this is what the
um i don't know if it is the same but
what's the fryer plot is trying to
um i haven't seen i've never heard of a
fried pot it's when you take it maybe
that's a rediscovery of the same thing
when you take the vector differences
right
you're when you have elongated region
they're going to look differently than
than when you have a round region
because they're going to be aligning
more now i understand the things that
these
these things that got called foxwell
from variables
which i had nicknamed at one point the
three animal variables
um were uh you know their idea
i mean they're used by particle physics
people um
but i mean their idea is you take um
let's see what do you do you take the
spherical harmonics or the
generalization
in d dimensions you take this
uh of of theta phi well actually we can
do the case
with in the you can do it just with
sines and cosines
in so i think i think it's just sine n
theta uh and you take the sum of those
over the actual points of the actual
values of theta for which
there are points you see what i'm saying
and um i mean i think that the the thing
here is given a center
right given a central position you're
simply looking
at the number of points
in each direction away from there
and then this is characterizing
basically whether that distribution of
points
as a function of n you get this thing as
a function of n and for example
i remember h2 is a good characterization
of whether the thing is kind of a
a um just elongated or whether it has
whether it's sprouted out another
another edge to it
um
uh
okay let's see um
okay i think that we should hold here
though for today i think we're
and then we schedule another one fine
preferably before too long because
otherwise
yeah no i agree we need to have it soon
but see if you can
you know work through the things that
we've already talked about here so next
time
we're starting from that point okay
yeah um and uh
yeah um
okay we've now missed another meeting
which was
i just want to know at least what it was
about um
where's the where's the p where's the um
at least let's just see the agenda just
so i know what we missed
um
um
where was that agenda
no no no for the other meeting yeah for
the other design review or
yeah for the other design the geography
should also be in the calendar if they
follow the rules
it's not sorry that's your team i'll
send it to you
well i don't know why it's not maybe
somebody can say is
jose do you know where the agenda is i
have it okay
it's in my collection except i sent it
to them and i asked them to put it in
there and they didn't
oh wait a minute no no it is incorrect
it is in fact here
i just want to see what this is about
roughly
oh wow vector geographics that's
exciting
and super exciting
really you've managed to make this work
well these are partial examples of how
you handle labels we have
i can send you
examples of actual maps let me send you
a notebook
that's really exciting so so you mean
you've managed to get the vector
vector geographics working now
yes in a state that we consider it
experimental
but we have several styles
we can handle labels correctly and yeah
it's working pretty well
you'll see in the notebook i just sent
you okay
do you want to go on with that meeting
now stephen uh we probably shouldn't
um but oh this is beautiful
this is one of our styles but it's so
crisp
thank goodness we finally have this
oh that's so great
why is it experimental how do we get it
out of being experimental
well the problem is that we are there
are so incredibly many details here that
we are finalizing
some of them right now and so we are a
bit concerned
with having this as the default but
certainly people should opt in by just
specifying the background they want
background style
we have a collection of them oh can we
make this packet upgradeable
so that we can really roll this out it
already is
so the we already have a audio backlit
which is being installed it was
installed recently in your machine
to play with this and uh look at this
map this is fantastic
this is so much better than we've ever
had before
how much data is there in these maps is
that is there is this
actually what is the download size the
first one
is about seven megabytes i mean big
cities city centers
are heavy and and
right now it's a bit slow but as it
happens with
the image geographics we will iterate
and make it faster
do we understand the the flow of why
it's slow
i mean is it transferring bits that's
slow or is it something to do with
rendering that's slow
it's a bit both things but at the moment
the main bottleneck is the data
the transfer of data so francisco has
made
the tiles in in groups to accelerate
things
and then there was a discussion of
putting everything into the cdn which is
moving on
and that's now that we need to have
right
i'm really excited to see this this is
really crisp and lovely
i mean especially i mean the fact that
both the labels are crisp
and the um the features
are crisp is really good but i mean even
just the labels being crisp would be a
big improvement
right and now this is all vector so we
can
control layers we can we can control we
can have multiple styles with the same
data because the data comes separate
from the style
right i understand but so if i take this
and i just go
so you're saying this has the full level
of detail of every
of every um
and there is a question here look at
that poor tower that fell down
what isn't that notre dame
don't you damn no it's not judaism one
of the islands
this is an island it's in the
in there exactly
yes right and that's presumably the
tower that fell down
i don't know what it might say what's
that i i don't know the reason why this
is not colored
well i assume it's because it collapsed
right isn't that the
yeah it didn't collapse
in there maybe it doesn't have its roof
there so it isn't it isn't filled
in
so now in the front end wait a minute
i'm complaining here because i'm not
this this scrolling the front end is
getting scratchy
so this tile was not re i didn't
i have all of the data then everything
every piece of data about the center of
paris
is here is that correct in in this in
this download that i have yes
this is seven megabytes of primitives
and so so for example this cross
hatching this is our cross-hatching is
that right
i guess i think so i think that's what
francisco's using
but is it really necessary can we not
down sample this
we can we are now full control on on
zooms and what to put in each zoom
okay okay fine so then so then it would
be
vector graphics but it might not have i
mean you know
having every door handle shown on each
of these buildings
is not going to happen at the zoom level
for example exactly
one can go deeper than load zoom 14
or whatever and then you have a lot more
data but it will be a more
expensive graphics and download time
right and uh look look at that why is
that that accented character looks wrong
so another question is given that this
is all vector graphics can i
select is there any way i can select
this
this text
oh my god really that really
yeah you can move works until we disable
it
[Laughter]
which i mean i think is one of the you
know things that we were discussing
recently is that
by default you probably shouldn't be
able to select
general map elements wait a minute this
didn't work i i tried pasting from this
oh it's probably white text on a white
background
oh
so you're saying if i go here
i see so there's a graphics piece no
there we go so there it is
well
so so if i can select map elements that
means i can actually edit this map
what do you mean oh my god they really
are vector graphics
why does it select only those pieces
it looks like they've organized graphics
groups or
grouping you know i would guess
that it's polygons you know grouped by
number of vertices for efficiency
purposes
yes we have grouped lines for example so
there is also the
having things together so that they
project faster
oh i see yeah okay so this is pretty
crazy this selection is crazy i mean
while it's amusing to light up pieces of
paris here
i think the selection is crazy
um
okay right so here
we we had to handle multiple things
including
labels and separation between labels and
styles there is also ongoing work on
improving all the styles
and we have this is really important
this is really nice and really important
but by the way you did notice my
complaint about the front end
scroll speed now
yes yes in general we have seen that
graphics behaves quite well i mean i i
have done i have done other different
cases with hundreds of megabytes of data
and it was with time was able to show it
but yes i mean these maps are heavy load
for
is this going to work what i'm doing
here
i expect it to be bitmapped and probably
this look
you know poor but
not terrible that's really not terrible
i mean these got bit mapped as you
expected and some of them
didn't render perfectly but it's not
embarrassing
i mean the hatching came across the
worst of anything i think
at least over zoom but yeah it's on dls
too
too
um cool okay
i'm going to make a comment actually
about this the way this publishing thing
works i realized we should we need
something here
where i can get um
i don't understand why i can't get the
purely published version
um as opposed to
um
let's see the the purely published
version which is not what as i would see
it
or maybe i did get that i did that's the
obj
thing never mind silly message
okay um
uh there's a question about do we have
map styles implanted we are working on
map styles that was yes that is one of
these um
why not cache it as a bitmap uh yes
we this is yes um
we don't need to cache this as a bitmap
because we can render fast enough
um at a given tile resolution all right
and this time so we do cache there there
right so now the question is how do we
feed this into spatial statistics
so let's say i take the buildings in
paris
that's another hour-long meeting
probably
yes that cannot be done right now so
these we get
the vector primitives to be drawn we
cannot get
something like give me all the streets
yes that requires a different service in
the geo server
right although we know that that's
possible i mean like there's samples
that like christopher had a sample and
other people have had samples
of um uh uh you know getting the street
network and so on right
it will be possible it's just that we
are working very hard on this part of
the project first
right i understand makes sense okay
great we should wrap
up here so we need to continue this
other stuff on a different meeting
and several more things to do and um
uh great and i think i had made some
changes here so i need to push my
changes back right
roger you you recall i made changes to
these documentation pages right
yes yeah i will you will run into
conflicts but just push
my system yeah my system auto pushes so
unfortunately i am prepared for that so
okay terrific cool
nicole um the okay great all right
thanks guys great stuff to be continued
thanks to folks on the live stream
see you all actually i'm gonna see uh if
you join
there's a later live stream about form
notebooks in a little bit less than an
hour
so uh join it check out what form
notebooks are i don't think we've live
streamed about those at all yet
a new and exciting thing that's coming